Coffee on Tuesday and blog for,
do they want to talk about the peaceful
protests currently happening in Lower
Manhattan called Occupy Wall Street.
It's starting to get some buzz in the
mainstream media,
which I watched obsessively and also the
rosy eyes of Michael Moore,
so you know it's legitimate.
So occupy Wall Street is a leaderless
protests with a vague set of demands.
It started by Canadian activist group
called ad busters and the names,
the model of the protest from Tahrir
Square in Egypt last March,
which unseated their President Mubarak.
The Tahrir Square protest had a simple
but intense demand move.
Bark must resign.
The protest in Liberty Park is crowded
with lots of littler,
less forceful demand.
Some of the come to protest
unemployment,
some protests,
the wealth inequality in this country,
some of the wars,
some of the corruption of campaign
finance laws,
some environmental issues,
and some of them just to create a
spectacle despite their demands.
Presumably everybody is angry at the
same thing.
The reckless abandoned perpetrated on
Wall Street which caused the subprime
mortgage crisis in 2008.
Maybe we should take a minute to
understand the financial crisis.
One Minute,
so Wall Street started bundling home
loans together and selling slices of
those loans to investors.
Investors were making big money,
so they started pushing the lender
saying,
we need more loans.
Lenders,
we're already giving people loans with
good credit,
so they started lowering their criteria
used to be you needed a credit score of
six,
20 and a down payment of 20 percent and
they'll settle for a 500 credit score
and no money down.
Joe Schmo buyer assumes that at the
bank's willing to lend him money that he
must be able to afford it.
He buys his dream house banks.
New Securities based on bad mortgages
were risky.
So to control potential fallout,
they started buying insurance mortgages.
Default,
the insurance company pays default swap,
so the banks have potential losses.
In short,
the risk moves off their books.
They invest more.
One insurance company took on more swaps
than any other American international
group.
Why did they do this?
Feeds premiums millions.
How'd you think of the housing market?
We keep going up,
but then all of a sudden the housing
prices go down.
Joe Schmo buyer bought his dream house
at a teaser rate mortgage.
Now that rate goes away,
payments go up.
He defaults mortgage back securities
tank.
Aig has to pay off the swaps,
all of them at the same time,
all over the world.
They can't afford it,
of course,
so the government does this.
The government under treasury secretary
Hank Paulson,
passes the emergency economic
stabilization act through which they can
purchase troubled assets and inject
capital into the banks from a fund
called the troubled asset relief
program,
which holds a cool $700,
billion.
Now,
the quick legislation did prevent a
catastrophe,
but it didn't stop people from losing
confidence.
It didn't stop people from holding onto
their money.
It didn't stop them from not consuming
the goods and services of this economy.
So demand goes down.
The economy contracts,
businesses stop hiring and three years
later,
not enough,
I think Wilson said this on Charlie rose
in 2008 constituents were angry and they
had a right to be angry.
They had no part in making this the
constituents,
that's us.
He had no part in making this,
but did we?
Are we guiltless?
They had no part in making this or have
we as consumers pushed and pushed for
years,
every corporation to get us the best
deals on our goods and the best returns
on our investments are we complicit in a
system which was driven to do anything
to be Buffett stock value and lower its
prices on goods,
even to the point of selling bundling
and gambling on bad mortgages so that we
could get tee shirts at 20th.
Capitalism has strengthened the part of
our brain that our consumers and
investors,
super capitalism has made us
terrifically adept at thinking of
ourselves and practicing being very,
very efficient and adept.
Consumers and investors,
don't get me wrong,
this is not to say that the Wall Street
titans are blameless,
but each of us are made up of two parts.
The part that is a consumer and the part
that is a citizen.
Yes,
Washington is awash with corporate
lobbyists,
but what are those lobbyists actually
doing?
Most of those lobbyists are there in
Washington to get a competitive
advantage over their competitors who are
also in Washington trying to use public
policies to get a competitive advantage
over their competitors.
The noise level is so high that the
public,
you and I cannot be heard,
at least the citizen cannot be here,
the consumer and investor in us.
Here's the only voice that is being
heard.
We're going to have to be willing to
give up some of the benefits that the
consumer side of ourselves has gotten in
the last few decades and certainly it's
important as citizens that we exercise
our rights like the people in Liberty
Park are doing right now,
but perhaps it's more important that as
Americans,
we exercise our privileges.
One of our privileges is to learn and
study anything we want and do it
systematically.
It's important that we lead with reason
and not emotion.
People are angry and frustrated and
worried about their jobs.
If they feel that they are not getting
ahead and if they feel that the dice are
loaded against them,
that somehow the economy is is fixed.
That government and business are in
cahoots.
That's when you ignite the kind of
social change that could be very
progressive and very reform minded,
but also could be very reactionary,
separate some cool articles in the
jubilee to about this.
Thanks for listening and.